so donald trump very recently pardoned
his convicted former national security
adviser michael flynn
and flynn is already out there calling
for donald trump to execute
a military coup to retain control of the
white house beyond january 20th despite
the fact that it's very
uncontroversially true that joe biden
won the 2020 presidential election
and things have become so debased
that this story is barely making
headlines this is the story of
a former top national security official
who has been convicted and then pardoned
by the president
for crimes related to protecting that
president who immediately
after being pardoned is out saying
declare martial law
and uh effect a military coup to retain
power
michael flynn endorsed a call on twitter
for trump to go absolutely dictatorial
this is a call from a group
called the people the we the people
convention which says donald trump
should invoke
martial law and just have a new election
didn't like the result of the first one
we'll do a new one
martial law is when you impose military
control over functions normally handled
by civilian government
it's typically something that is done
only in extreme emergencies like really
extenuating circumstances not
he lost and he wanted to win you lost
and you wanted to win is not
a circumstance in which you uh invoke
martial law
now really we have to understand how
dangerous this arc is
michael flynn commits crimes in his role
as incoming and actual trump national
security adviser
he's investigated trump fires him
seems to understand that trump uh that
flynn did the things he's accused of
doing
flynn cooperates with the fbi sort of
is uh convicted but robert mueller
recommends
no jail time michael flynn then recants
part of his cooperating testimony
then trump pardons flynn whose crimes
are related to protecting trump himself
and within days michael flynn former
national security adviser endorses the
idea of donald trump declaring martial
law
and holding a new election willy-nilly
because he didn't like the results of
the election that we had
once again colloquially speaking what
michael flynn is doing
is sedition sedition is conduct or
speech
inciting people to rebel against the
authority of a state or monarch
that's what this former national
security adviser
is calling for here fresh off of a
pardon
for crimes related to protecting donald
trump
pardoned by donald trump himself the guy
pardoned by trump for crimes
meant to protect trump is calling for
trump
to use the military to stay in power
despite having lost the election
understand how absurd that is every
individual by oh and there's another
layer to this
uh the day before yesterday trump's
press secretary
kelly mcinanny when uh she was asked
about pardons
and with whether trump would pardon
giuliani or his children as he's
reportedly considering
uh kaley said the only pardon i can talk
about is the one that happened
for three star general michael flynn
now there's something interesting there
when uh
when someone serves in the military they
take
an oath and that oath
doesn't expire when you leave
active service you take an oath when you
enter the military to defend the
constitution
of the united states against all enemies
foreign and domestic
the veterans oath doesn't expire and so
on every level it's particularly
ridiculous
that michael flynn is out there saying
invoke martial law
take it put make a new election because
you lost
but the really crazy part is they want
us to believe
they are the patriotic ones by doing
this even though what they are doing
is the opposite of you know more
properly and sensibly defined patriotism
they are
advocating uh for for the opposite
of patriotism they are they are part of
the domestic threats that they are
as members of the military supposed to
be protecting us against
they believe and certainly claim
that they are the patriotic ones by
doing this this
national nightmare has gone on way too
long
we're down to six and a half weeks but
who knows what they have planned even
after joe biden is inaugurated scary to
think about
our sponsor purevpn is having a huge
black friday sale
right now they're giving you 88 office
subscription
which comes out to only a little over a
dollar a month
purevpn makes you anonymous when you're
browsing online and you can trust them
because they're the only vpn in the
industry with an always-on
third-party audit to verify that your
internet activity is not being logged
by hiding your ip address purevpn keeps
you safe from hackers
and prevents you from being spied on by
your internet service provider
social media companies and even
government surveillance
it also lets you watch shows and movies
that aren't available in your country
purevpn is super fast you can use it on
all of your devices
and i can tell you firsthand the app is
really easy to use
and they have 6500 servers across the
world which is more than
any other vpn in the industry everyone
should be using
a vpn when connecting to the internet
and now is the perfect time to start
because purevpn is giving you an 88
discount on a subscription which comes
out to only a little over a dollar a
month
go to davidpakman.com purevpn
the link is underneath the video